karina escurrió el agua de una cubeta
sea w de tela cantidad de agua w medida
en mililitros que quedan dentro de la
cubeta después de t segundos cuál de las
ecuaciones representa mejor el siguiente
enunciado y el enunciado es el siguiente
dice en los primeros 25 segundos la
cantidad de agua disminuyó por un
promedio de 4 mililitros cada segundo
muy bien entonces lo que voy a hacer es
tratar de reescribir esta frase en
términos de algo que conocemos muy bien
y es la tasa de cambio promedio verdad
entonces la tasa de cambio promedio la
tasa de cambio promedio por supuesto hay
que decir de qué variable verdad y la
tasa desde w que es el agua que queda
dentro de la cubeta y hay que decir
también en qué intervalo de tiempo y
aquí estamos pensando en los primeros 25
segundos ok la tasa de cambio promedio
de w en los primeros
cinco segundos vamos a decirlo así aquí
está en los primeros 25 de los primeros
25 segundos la cantidad de agua
disminuyó por un promedio de 4
mililitros cada segundo eso quiere decir
que esta tasa de cambio es 4 mililitros
4 mililitros por segundo sin embargo
aquí hace falta algo hace falta un signo
menos porque porque estamos hablando de
que esta tasa es negativa porque está
disminuyendo la cantidad de agua dentro
de la cubeta muy bien así que ahora lo
que tenemos que hacer es reescribir esto
en términos digamos un poco más
matemáticos verdad y la tasa de cambio
promedio le escribimos como un cociente
de variables que cambian verdad y para
denotar eso ponemos el cambio en w
dividido entre el cambio del tiempo es
igual a y bueno simplemente hay que
calcularlo verdad el cambio de w es la
cantidad de agua al final es decir en el
segundo 25
menos la cantidad de agua inicial que
queda en la cubeta verdad
ok ahí tenemos el cambio en la variable
w que es la cantidad de agua dividido
entre el cambio en el tiempo verdad por
supuesto pues podemos pensar que el
cambio en el tiempo es el tiempo final
menos el tiempo inicial verdad 25 es el
final 0 es el inicial pero bueno esto
simplemente lo lo escribimos como 25
verdad 25 menos 0 es 25 muy bien y esto
nos tiene que dar lo mismo que menos 4
eso es exactamente lo que dice aquí
arriba pero en términos más matemáticos
verdad así que si comparamos estas
cuatro opciones sólo tenemos como
candidatos puede ser este-oeste de hecho
éste coincide completamente con la
solución que acabamos de dar ahora bien
está esta segunda opción se parece mucho
vamos a ver por qué ésta no puede ser
bueno de entrada aquí hace falta el
signo menos verdad qué
nos habla de la disminución verdad por
ejemplo qué pasaría si fuera esta
segunda qué es lo que nos estaría
diciendo este enunciado bueno 25 es una
cantidad positiva verdad entonces para
que nos dé una una cantidad positiva que
de hecho es 4 el numerador también
tendría que ser positivo verdad de qué
forma el numerador puede ser positivo
bueno esto es algo muy fácil verdad
estamos haciendo una resta de dos
cantidades para que sea positiva la
primera de ellas la primera de ellas
tiene que ser muy al menos mayor que la
segunda verdad puede ser mucho más
grande no importa tiene que ser mayor
que la segunda eso que nos dice que la
cantidad de agua después de 25 segundos
que quedaban en la cubeta es mayor a la
que había inicialmente eso no tiene
sentido verdad porque estamos diciendo
que el agua está escurriendo de la
cubeta es decir nos estamos quedando con
menos agua en cada ocasión y aquí nos
está diciendo que que por alguna razón
estamos metiendo más agua en la cubeta y
esto
tiene sentido sin embargo en esta de
abajo si tiene sentido verdad porque
estamos dividiendo entre 25 y queremos
que nos dé un número negativo así que
esto que tenemos en el numerador tiene
que ser negativo y para que esto sea
negativo la primera cantidad tiene que
ser más pequeña que la segunda lo cual
quiere decir que al final tenemos menos
agua del agua que teníamos inicialmente